-This year, our first guest
became a four-time Emmy-winning
actor, director, writer, and
producer all in the same night.
He stars in a new film
called "Happiest Season,"
which premieres November 25th
on Hulu.
Here is Dan Levy. Hey!
Dan, look at you. Come on.
-Hey, Jimmy.
-Hey, this year,
the final season
of "Schitt's Creek" aired,
and you completely
swept the Emmys
and broke all these records.
And I want to tell
everyone watching
that we're not allowed
to say the name of your show
without seeing the logo.
That's why when I say
"Schitt's Creek,"
it pops up every time we say it.
-It'll come somewhere.
-Yeah.
But it's been a little while
since the Emmys,
and I haven't talked to you.
Has that night sunk in yet?
What was it like?
-No, first of all,
it was absolute madness.
And, no, it will never sink in.
I don't think any of us, when we
walked into that strange tent
in the backyard
of an event space in Toronto,
really had any indication
of what was going to happen.
We kind of describe it like
you know those kind of, like,
"Host a Murder" board games
where you invite
a bunch of friends over,
and each of you comes prepared
with, like...
-Yes.
-...what's your part?
You're the doctor.
You're the suspicious aunt.
It was like we were being hosted
at one of those murder
dinner parties,
except we were all
given the character of, like,
"You're nominated for an award."
And then instead of someone
getting murdered at the dinner,
we just all got Emmys.
It was, like, the greatest night
of my life.
-It was great.
And there's even more
congratulations
in order for you,
because "People's"
Sexiest Man Alive issue
comes out this Friday,
and look who made the list.
Look at this. Come on.
-Yeah.
-Double page spread?
-[ Laughs ]
-How does that feel?
-The best part about this
is it's, like --
Sure, it's Sexiest Man Alive,
but I get
the "In Quarantine" part.
So there's, like --
There's, like, Michael B.
Jordan, which is much deserved,
and then I'm kind of the one
that's, like, peeking my head
out of the house
being like, "I've been in here
for 67 straight days!"
-[ Laughs ]
-But, listen.
-No, you --
-A great honor.
-I hear that quarantine led you
to discover reality TV.
You've never
watched reality TV before?
-Well, I mean,
I worked in reality --
Before I did the show,
I was working on MTV
with "The Hills"
for a long time,
a show that
some people might know.
-I love "The Hills."
-And I was doing the aftershow
for "The Hills."
And when you work so closely
with a reality television show,
and I loved "The Hills" --
-Yeah, me, too.
-But it kind of takes the magic
out of the experience
of watching reality television,
'cause you kind of end up
knowing too much
about how it works.
-Yeah.
-So I had to take,
like, a long hiatus,
and then quarantine happened,
and I had quite literally
watched every show
on television,
and so I finally
just resolved myself
to just accepting the fact that
I only have reality TV left.
Not to diminish the genre,
but it started,
and then it became a problem.
-Because it's the best thing
that's ever existed.
-Well, because I couldn't stop
watching it,
and now I guess
it's all I watch.
-Yeah. Me, too. What's your jam?
What are you watching?
-I started with
a "Real Housewives of Atlanta."
I ended with
a "Below Deck Mediterranean."
-Oh, my God.
That's my jam, "Below Deck."
I'm so -- Captain Sandy?
-Have you caught up, though?
-Captain Sandy or Captain Lee?
-Captain Sandy --
-Oh, yeah.
-The drama that happens
on the last season of
"Below Deck Mediterranean" is...
-It's unbelievable.
-...earth-shattering.
-I'm a Hannah fan,
from way back.
-I have many times thought about
vacationing to Australia
to take Hannah's
yachting course.
-I'll go with you.
Does she really do that?
'Cause I will go with you.
We should do that.
-Yeah, that's what she does now.
She's teaching a course
on how to be a yachtie.
And I thought --
Should we go?
-Dude, I will definitely --
I'm there. Are you kidding me?
-Okay.
-The show is --
The whole drama with Hannah,
I was like, "What is going on?"
-I would last 25 seconds
on that ship.
-I can't even.
It was just -- Yeah, I agree.
-[ Laughs ]
-I want to talk
about your new movie.
-Yeah.
-It is called "Happiest Season."
It is a great, feel-good
holiday movie.
Kristen Stewart is, you know,
one of my all-times.
I just love her so much, man.
And I love the plot.
I think -- I mean, it just
works, and it's funny.
You want to tell everyone
what it's about?
-Yeah. Well, it's the first
studio lesbian rom-com,
Christmas rom-com.
So, round of applause
to Clea DuVall,
who got that one
off of the ground.
-Good for Clea DuVall.
-And it's about two women
who are falling in love,
and Mackenzie Davis' character
invites Kristen Stewart's
character home for the holidays.
And then just as they're
pulling into the driveway,
we realize that Mackenzie
has not come out to her family
and that Kristen will have to
sort of go along with
or not go along with this idea
that they're now going to
play into something that
her parents don't know about.
And I play Kristen's
best friend,
who is not having
any of the mayhem.
And I think -- Yeah.
-It's super fun.
It's, like, holiday good times.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Dan Levy
in "Happiest Season."
Take a look at this.
[ Indistinct conversations ]
-[ Whispering ] Abby.
Abby!
[ Clears throat ]
Sorry.
What?
-Um...
How are you here?
-When are you going to get this?
I have been tracking you.
Oh, oh --
[ Clears throat ]
-Hello.
-Hi.
-I'm Tipper. This is my home.
-Oh.
-Are you the ex-boyfriend?
-[ Clears throat ] Y-Yes.
I'm...John, Abby's
heterosexual ex-boyfriend,
and I have come to get her back.
-Mm, I see.
Well, it would have been nice
to have known you were coming.
But since you are here, enjoy.
-Thank you so much.
Okay, I nailed that,
and she is fabulous.
-Dan, I'd love to play
a new game with you.
Would you mind sticking around?
-Hell yes.
-More with Dan Levy
after the break!
Come on back, everybody!